cuba recibe ayuda aliada este domingo la
nación caribeña acogió la asistencia de
los gobiernos de méxico y venezuela para
tratar de controlar el incendio en la
principal instalación de almacenamiento
de petróleo causado por un rayo el
pasado viernes en la provincia
occidental de matanzas a disposición
oportuna
con la que se ofrece ayuda de un
presidente a los de bajos del presidente
méxico y venezuela respectivamente
según mayca no conjuga manifestarlo
a disposición de ayudar sin tomar en
cuenta ninguna condición sin tomar en
cuenta ninguna demora sin tomar ningún
retraso hasta el momento 82 mexicanos y
35 venezolanos con experiencia en la
lucha contra los incendios de
combustible se unieron a las tareas de
extinción llevando cuatro aviones con
productos químicos ayudar
el incendio por medio de enfriamiento a
base de agua y espuma
en próximas horas nos lleguen más apoyos
así como el material químico necesario
para apoyar este incendio en la isla que
ya deja más de un centenar de heridos
evidencia que la pérdida de combustible
puede seguir agravando la escasez y los
apagones habituales en los últimos meses